with just three days to go before the
midterm elections it's a tale of dueling
presidents on the campaign trail
President Trump and former President
Barack Obama are not on the ballot
Tuesday but you wouldn't know it from
the way they've been barnstorming around
the country in the final days before the
election
both were in Florida on Friday
supporting rival candidates in that
state type battles for governor and the
Senate this weekend we'll see them
making stops in a total of seven states
ed O'Keefe is traveling with the
president and joins us from Indianapolis
at good morning good morning Dana
despite government data showing the
economy added more than a quarter of a
million new jobs the president still
banking on immigration to drive voters
to the polls and that focus on his
signature issue comes as he acknowledges
that his party may be on the verge of
losing the House of Representatives it
could happen could happen we're doing
very well and we're doing really well in
the Senate but could happen don't worry
about it I'll just figure it out
the president campaigning Friday in West
Virginia one of several states where
Republicans hope to pick up a Senate
seat and pad their slim majority as he
spoke Friday night in Indianapolis
former President Obama was speaking in
Atlanta and both at each other on their
minds
Barack
H Obama
Barack Obama folks in the highest levels
votes folks who we thought our children
should be looking up to well just
blatantly repeatedly boldly shamelessly
Obama is scheduled to make stops Sunday
for fellow Democrats in Indiana and
Illinois you believe in the American
Constitution you got to know that no one
person can decide who is an American
citizen on the stump mr. Trump remains
primarily focused on immigration
believing that attacking Democrats on
the issue will work they want these
caravans full of illegal aliens to flood
into our country overwhelming your
school's depleting your resources and
endangering your community's people
standing in line for hours to see the
president say immigration is exactly
what he should focus on this country
I think the money ought to go to them
before it goes to the illegals so with
all of his traveling you might wonder
when the president himself might be
voting well the White House tells us
that mr. and mrs. Trump recently voted
by absentee ballot they are of course
registered right where you are Michelle
in the great state of New York all right
New Jersey see valid or myself okay
thank you very much